we're told that ahmat tried to write x
to the fourth plus five x squared plus
four as a product of linear factors
this is his work and then they tell us
all the steps that he did and then they
say in what step did ahmad make his
first mistake
so pause this video and see if you can
figure that out
all right now let's work through this
together
so we're starting with x to the fourth
plus 10x squared plus nine
and it looks like ahmad tried to factor
that into x squared plus 9 times x
squared plus 1.
and this indeed does make sense because
if we said that let's say u
is equal to
x squared we could rewrite this right
over here as
u squared
plus 10
u
plus 9. the whole reason why you would
do this is so that you could write this
higher order expression in terms of a
second degree expression and then we've
learned how to factor things like this
many times we look we say okay what two
numbers when i add them i get 10 and
when i multiply them i get 9 and it
would be 9 and 1 and so you could write
this as
u plus 9 times u plus 1 and of course if
u is equal to x squared this would be x
squared plus 9 times x squared plus 1
which is exactly what a mod has right
over here so step 1 is looking great
all right now let's think about what
amot did in step two they didn't do
anything to x squared plus nine but it
looks like they tried to further factor
x squared plus one
and this does seem right we just have to
remind ourselves just as you have a
difference of squares if you're dealing
with non-complex numbers so we could
rewrite this right over here as
x plus a times x minus a
we could have a sum of squares if we're
thinking about complex numbers this is
going to be x plus a i
times x minus a
i and in this situation well the x is x
and then our a would be 1 so we're going
to have x plus 1 i
x plus 1 i times x minus 1 i so step 2
is looking great and now let's go to
step three so in step three
no change to this part of the expression
and it looks like a mod is trying to
factor x squared plus nine based on the
same principle now x squared plus nine
is the same thing as x squared
plus 3 squared so if you use this exact
same idea here if you factor it it
should be x plus
3 i
times x minus
3i
but what we see over here is a mott took
the square root of three instead of just
having a three here amon treated it
instead of having a nine here as if we
actually had a three so they made a
little bit of an error there so this is
the step where amot makes his first
mistake and we're done